[Applause]
even before the matches had started
there are enough headlines to fill the
back pages
just 15 minutes before kickoff and
thousands of England and Iranian fans
were still queuing outside Khalifa
Stadium to get in
the World Cup app had crashed and with
it their digital tickets to enter the
ground
hours before on the morning of the match
itself FIFA band Harry Kane and Gareth
Bale from wearing one love Captain's
armbands and threatened undefined
sporting sanctions if they did England
and Wales decided it wasn't worth the
risk but didn't mask their annoyance
letting political statements into
footballs problematic was where do you
draw the line I think it's a bit silly
that if they're going to invite people
to their country they're going to host
this and they're going to take so much
money from it then you know everyone
should be equal right we're all here for
the same thing so um yeah I think you
should be allowed to it's totally wrong
but I I would like to think that England
would have stuck by their decision you
should or shouldn't I think you
shouldn't why not because he said well
so it's a football game no bloody world
society the FIFA rules are everyone has
to wear the same band so everyone needs
to be in agreement
England weren't the only side wanting to
make a statement though the Iranian
players refused to sing the national
anthem in support of the protests back
home booze and whistles from the crowd
drowned out the music
this took enormous bravery they are high
profile Sportsmen in Iran a football mad
Nation just over the water from Qatar
their group Defiance at the regime
didn't go unnoticed inside the stadium
and it might not go unpunished when they
return to Iran there is a pressure from
governmental and the national team so
don't react to anything or whatever just
[Music]
just please see something I put on black
to support the death back in Iran I
didn't put on the Iraq is that what
you've done yeah yeah I I love my
national team I that's the reason I came
here but I want to show my Consultants
with the people that were killing here
yeah we are here for support my uh
Iranian boys and just not support my
national team we are support for people
just people
before kickoff England players took the
knee despite FIFA's efforts to keep
politics out of football there is just
too much to ignore here in Qatar
[Music]
the organizers hoped that when the
football started the controversy would
stop it hasn't
Alistar bunkel Sky News in Qatar